foreign
large understanding ethical hacking is
crucial by dwelling into the world of
ethical hacking you gain a deep
comprehension of hacker techniques and
vulnerabilities which will enable you to
strengthen your security measures with
the demand for cyber Security
Professionals soaring learning ethical
hacking opens doors to wide range of
exciting career opportunities moreover
it empowers you to protect your personal
data and privacy while staying one step
ahead of evolving cyber threats by
embracing ethical hacking responsibly
you contribute to a safer digital
environment enhance problem-solving
skills and Foster continuous growth get
ready to embark on an exciting journey
into the realm of ethical hacking and
discover as immense value in today's
interconnected world and if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elects to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a shot
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security from schwarzman's College
of computing in collaboration with EC
Council the link in the description box
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
take action upskill and get ahead but
before we begin if these are the type of
videos you'd like subscribe button and
click on the Bell to never miss an
update from Simply love without further
Ado let's get started with understanding
why we must learn ethical hacking there
are a wide variety of reasons of why to
learn ethical hacking let's discuss the
important ones firstly cyber security
awareness next strengthen security
measures carrier opportunities
protection of personal data awareness of
cyber threats ethical use of skills
problem solving and continuous learning
now that we have few important reasons
let's discuss each one of these
important reasons in a bit more detail
firstly cyber security awareness
learning about ethical hacking provides
you with a deep understanding of the
techniques and methods used by hackers
this knowledge helps you identify
vulnerabilities in your computer systems
networks and applications enabling you
to better protect them
the next one is strengthening security
measures by learning ethical hacking you
can actively contribute to improving the
security of computer systems ethical
hackers often identify weaknesses in
organizations networks and provide
recommendations for enhancing security
measures
followed by that we have career
opportunities the field of cyber setting
and there is a high demand for scale
professionals by acquiring knowledge of
ethical hacking you can open up various
career opportunities in Industries such
as I.T security Consulting penetration
testing and incidence response next
ahead we have protection of personal
data understanding ethical hacking
techniques empowers you to safeguard
your personal data with privacy you can
Implement security measures to protect
your devices online accounts and
sensitive information from potential
attacks
awareness of cyber threats is the next
one on the list
the digital landscape is constantly
evolving and new threats emerge
regularly learning ethical hacking helps
you stay up to date with the latest
cyber threats attack vectors and
vulnerabilities enabling you to
proactive your measures to mitigate the
risks
followed by that we have ethical use of
skills ethical hacking emphasizes the
responsible and legal use of hacking
techniques by learning ethical hacking
you gain the knowledge of the ethical
guidelines and legal boundaries
associated with cyber security this
ensures that your skills are utilized
for positive purposes protecting
individuals and organizations from
malicious attacks
next on the list is problem solving
skills ethical hacking requires critical
thinking problem solving and analytical
skills
through learning ethical hacking you
develop a systematic approach to
identifying and solving complex security
issues which can be valuable in various
aspects of life and other technical
domains
next on the list is continuous learning
and growth cyber security is a dynamic
field that demands continuous learning
to keep up with evolving cyber threats
learning ethical hacking ensures that
you remain engaged on ongoing education
and skill development first and personal
and professional growth
now let's get into the important aspect
of today's tutorial that is salary
details for a certified ethical hacker
in the United States of America the
salary of an ethical hacker can be based
on various factors such as experience
skill level location industry and the
organization they work for generally
ethical hackers in USA tend to earn
higher salaries than other countries due
to the demand for cyber Security
Professionals entry-level positions may
start around 60 to 80 000 per annum
while experienced professionals with
Advanced certifications and specialized
skills can earn salaries exceeding 150
000 per annum the salary of physical
hacker in India can vary depending on
factors such as experience skill set
location and organization they work for
on an average a beginner level ethical
hacker in engine from 3 lakhs to 6 lakhs
per annum as they gain more experience
and expertise
their salary can increase significantly
experience ethical hackers with several
years of experience and advanced
certifications can earn salaries ranging
from 8 to 20 lakhs or more annually now
proceeding with the company's hiring
ethical hackers several companies hire
ethical hackers to enhance their cyber
security defenses and protect their
systems here are some prominent
companies known for hiring ethical
hackers Google Facebook Microsoft Apple
Amazon IBM Cisco Intel Deloitte and ey
are the most prominent ones on that note
I would also like to share my personal
opinion on ethical hacking remember
ethical hacking should always be
conducted with legal and ethical
boundaries respect for privacy and
adherence to ethical guidelines are
essential for using ethical hacking
skills responsibly and positively
impacting cyber security
before we end this video let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers
[Music]
you're never too old to learn anything
new whether it's an art a new language a
new sport or learning new skills to
advance your career hi I'm Phillip I'm
61 years old and last year I upskilled
with simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security after working 30 years
in the I.T sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course funny
story I want to share with you
I started off aspiring to be a DJ where
I became interested in electronic stereo
systems and how they connected and how
they operate and what made them function
and four years ago I began a journey to
understand and learn more about the
cloud on the way I develop a natural
understanding of the security needs and
began to focus my studies to understand
more about the cyber security aspect of
the cloud landscape
I work with many companies before the
security analyst and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course I've been an adjunct
faculty member at particulars in college
and been in many different learning and
training experiences but the experience
as a student is simply learning
something I will always cherish of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors I believe
in living a fulfilling life at 61. I am
still trained students in martial arts
I've been practicing martial arts for
the past 40 years and my efforts were
acknowledged by the Eastern United
States International Martial Arts
Association
where I was inducted into the Hall of
Fame for a lifetime achievement of
dedication service and martial arts I've
been many things in my life first and
foremost I've been a learner be a
learner first
with that we have reached to the end of
this video on violin ethical hacking if
you have any questions please feel free
to comment and we will have it answered
for you as soon as possible until next
time thank you for watching stay safe
keep learning and get ahead
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here